we have eight minutes to ask a question
and we're going to get there through
tangents and we're going to get there
through metaphors and we're going to do
it that way because this guy is a
diversion thinker and that's the term
where you get to a little bit later on
in this talk but for now the question
what do we take when we exit this is the
road out of this place it's the viewer
from the main quad down toward Palo Alto
and here at the business school we have
classes about extra strategies these
classes teach us how to take an idea
turn it into a product and exit with
that product into a marketplace the
names for these classes from idea to
launch from launch to liquidity dean
saloner is courting Buzz Lightyear for
next year seminar to liquidity and
beyond now in order to provide some
context for this question I'm going to
talk about an exit that I had in my life
it was not a liquidity events it was the
end of my dance career so we're going to
step through time I'm 21 years old I
have no college education and I'm
standing in front of a man who'll be
nominated for a Tony Award for the color
purple and he has just given me this
phrase of our movement
and he says Aaron put that movement into
your legs and I say Donald in my head no
arms are not legs they do not have the
same weights they don't have the same
joints they will not move the same way
this is crazy outside I go with him on
this tangent and I say okay I move my
leg around I step up to it and I jump
back as literal and interpretation as I
can think of and Donald says Aaron
that's not quite what we're looking for
how about make it cuter okay cute i can
do i put my hands behind my back I tap
my foot and I stick out my butt because
that's what cute does and no surprise
dances Aaron that is not a good look for
you
go pelvic floor sexy pelvic floor sexy
okay maybe I can do that I swing out my
leg I turn it around and I jump back and
thrust forward my pelvis and Donald says
that are this is the illustrative of an
eight year long journey through tangents
and metaphors stark visuals like go
pelvic floor sexy move through molasses
listen to the Rope of your arms cut the
air as a feather all designs to bring
texture to movement now I love my life
and I wasn't thinking about exits I was
lost in the content of the words that I
was experiencing it's no surprise if you
look up there pelvis features
prominently and I wasn't thinking about
exits because I thought I had time I
knew like all athletes and others my
career is going to end between 30 and 35
but as I was thinking I had time it
turns out I was wrong so for this next
part of the story let me put you in my
shoes it's two days before your 25th
birthday you wake up and you kiss the
person sitting next to you you pull on
blue jeans that you bought at goodwill
three weeks ago and you walk out into a
foggy San Francisco day you get on a bus
you get off a bus and at work you
exchange those blue tights blue jeans
for blue tights and you put on canvas
ballet slippers anytime tight so every
crevice of that canvas matches every
curve of your foot and you put your leg
up on that bar and you stretch and you
watch the Sun burns off the clouds into
what is turning into a beautiful day
your boss comes up behind you his name
is Michael Smulian and he has shocked
white hair he's put digital dance moves
on Yoda he's choreographed for Francis
Ford Coppola and he says to you next
year I want to choreograph a ballet for
you
Cyrano long nose and all what a great
day in the middle of class he says let's
have a jig petite Allegro small jumps
and the middle of the studio you can
feel the glue from those canvas shoes
cover your toes and you walk to the side
expecting a correction but when you look
back to the center of Michael something
is very wrong Michael isn't breathing
you're the first one at his side and he
put an arm over his shoulder and you say
loudly and clearly Michael stay with us
because you know hearing is the last
thing to go you pick him up and you put
him on the floor and you watch as his
eyes roll up into his head and close
Michael's death Michael's exit it is
poetic for many this man died doing what
he loved but for me it was a wake-up
call it's hard to make a joke at this
point in this story but if you look up
at this list pelvis on a resume so like
many others I went to Community College
monday to wednesday i was in night
school thursday to sunday i was dancing
and i was lucky to find myself here at
stanford university as an undergraduate
at the age of 28 at the age of 28 i was
watching a TED talk as part of
curriculum in a classroom let me say
that again so to understand I was
watching a TED talk as an assignment for
a class
sir ken robinson was speaking about the
value of creativity specifically
divergent thinking he was talking about
divergent thinking as the process of
creating value from an idea and a small
light went off in my head and it got
brighter and brighter and brighter as I
was watching this laptop and I thought
to myself oh my god my entire dance
career I was translating ideas into
motion and that was the value of my life
I am a divergent thinker that label had
power here at the GSB as we get ready
the students to leave I asked what are
the labels that we have what are the
processes that we do that are different
and could change our lives as we go out
of this place and for those of you who
are here today who are not students what
has just occurred in this room what do
we take when we exit now when I asked
that question I can't help but think of
a few things I think put my arms in my
legs I think through tangents and
metaphors and I ask what do you take
when you exit thanks
you
you